let's just think back to where we began
right
we said this topic is called
trigonometry right which is just about
measuring triangles that's what the name
means okay but very very quickly we
moved from trigonometry to a very
specific part of trigonometry namely all
this sine cos tan business right now
these are not trigonometry they just one
part of it they are the trigonometric
ratios and we went over this in our
first treat lesson we said sohcahtoa
officer my point music adjacent all the
different combination of the
combinations of those give you ratios
and we give the names and that's where
we started okay but you quickly realize
that this is a very limited way to
define these things and therefore this
right because have a look here's a
typical right angle triangle right and
if you wanted to work out what sine of
theta or cos of theta or tan of theta
and all of the reciprocals are you're
kind of limited right so you've got your
opposite your hypotenuse and your
adjacent here right so you can get
different ratios but feet are and we
noticed this in our proof by
contradiction about the tangent be
perpendicular to the radius we noticed
that theta automatically is locked into
a certain domain there are restrictions
on thena
what are the restrictions
good so yeah state is a cute basically
right uh this is this is a problem
because if we want to understand angles
right you don't even have to leave
triangles if I just push this triangle
over to the side right like so okay like
this an angle over here let's call it
alpha can I do treat with that angle yes
like if I look at this I cut because
it's not a cute anymore right so here by
definitions my very very narrow
definitions of the trig ratios they
immediately break down right and then
what about trig when the a was not in a
triangle right where's the opposite in
the hope there's no hypotenuse what do I
even do okay so this is a nice way to
start my angle triangles are a good
beginning right because they're
understandable but I'm very good right
when you think about obtuse angles or
reflex angles or bigger angles or what
about just battery angles what about
19th well I have a ninety degree there
what's the sine will cause of ten of
ninety how do I work out what these are
this definition isn't gonna fly okay and
that's why what we're going to do is
we're going to take this definition and
we want to understand not just ratios
what a move to ward trigonometric
functions I want you to think back to
the first time you heard the word
function right what is a function
function we tend to write with the
abbreviation f of X a function is just
something you can stick a number in and
get a number out
excuse me thank you okay simple concept
sticking a miracle index and out will
come another number let me call that f
of X right and we know all kinds of
functions already 2 X 3 X - 1 x squared
log of X blah blah blah blah blah okay
so what we want is can we define site or
closet and away such I can put any X you
like right not just not just within
isn't the to return spot such that I can
get a value out the other end
I want to generalize I want to blow open
my what I'm not be stuck in radical
trailers anymore okay so the way we're
gonna do this is with a circle not just
any sense this is the unit circle so it
has a radius of 1 right there's a radius
of 1 now the unit circle is inextricably
tied to the trig ratios and the trig
functions we shouldn't be that surprised
because as we were just explaining you
know even one of the basic functions
they delete and is named after a
component of a circle right so we should
expect this some kinda linky in fact in
some of the older textbooks that you
have a look at when they're looking at
sugar metric functions the chapter is an
even called trig electric version it's
called circular functions mmm
side cos tan that's what they're called
right so fundamental is the circle two
understandings ok so here's the way
we're gonna go through this here's your
unit circle and we're going to put one
of these right angle triangles in our
circle okay so I'm gonna put it right
here in the same orientation as my
that's not very little do okay
as my try and go over here okay so
now I've put it here and so I'm gonna
put my feet are in the same spot as well
so I actually have a fool yeah before I
go any further I want to immediately
draw your attention to the fact that why
do I start here I start here very on
purpose okay and it seems a bit
confusing because we have measured
angles around across looking thing
before when we did bearings remember
that
okay bearings we've looked at this but
this is a bit weird let me show you what
we do bearings we know how to do north
south east west etcetera okay but true
bearings which I've measured all the way
around
where did true bearings begin order on a
diagram North wears whether they start
they start at North right true north
okay and then we measure in in which
direction we go clockwise and this kinda
makes sense I suppose for bearings
because north is a sensible place to
begin right north like the most
important direction and clockwise while
it's clockwise because that's the way
our clocks go here right so why not
measure that way okay when we're in the
unit circle and when we're in
trigonometry okay things are completely
different so number one North is not the
starting point instead of North being a
starting point on here
it's what's east it's the x-axis that's
how starting point okay
not only is that different this is
different too we don't measure clockwise
we measure anti-clockwise now just
before I give a bit of an explanation I
want you to have a think why do they do
be the spirit why why do they make them
different we're both trying to
understand the same thing angles okay
why aren't would they not only change
the starting point but the direction as
we go through this I wonder if you will
start to see why this absolutely makes
sense in this
in fact if anything the bearings are the
ones which are a bit sort of arbitrary I
start with North okay
so that's an important note and that's
why I'm starting here on the x-axis and
my angle theta is measured
anti-clockwise you see that somebody
around the circle this way okay
now what do I have a look at is this
right angle triangle here okay and just
like in our very first question this
morning which is why start with her
right these sides here I can phrase in
terms of the trig ratios okay now if I
say okay wait up here on the
circumference of the unit circle okay I
want to know what its coordinates are
well it's coordinates come from
what's its x value horizontal and what's
its vibe wide vertical okay don't forget
it's the unit circle so what's the
hypotenuse equal to one okay so down
here here's my x value x equals now what
is X equal to right well I've got this
side down here and I know what the
hypotenuse is so being that this is FINA
which trig ratio should I choose which
will relate those two sides it's cosine
isn't it because I've got the Jason and
I've got hypotenuse in fact you can just
quickly mentally do it cause Athena will
be adjacent on hypotenuse X on one it's
just X right so X is just cause a filled
up that's what it's equal to
okay in exactly the same way when I look
at why I've got the opposite side this
time so sine of theta would be opposite
by hypotenuse is just Y so Y is equal to
sine theta
hmm so now I'm going to start to
romantic some Y for a second because I
can just talk in terms of theta
right so when I name these coordinates
up here the corner to the spot are close
theta Sophia whatever feeder maybe okay
so what have we done we have taken this
idea about right-angled triangles right
and we apply it to the circle and then
we've noticed this interesting
relationship that cause is the
x-coordinate of the point on the unit
circle corresponding to this angle let
me say that again the cosine of theta is
the x coordinate of the point on the
unit circle that corresponds to that
angle right and the sine of theta is the
Y value right so I'm now going to change
gears this is weird I am just gonna stop
defining sine and cos in terms of this
triangle I'm now going to define sine
and cos in terms of this circle okay
like in fact yeah if I drew a new unit
circle right and I put like a dot over
there okay I can define that point as
closely that sign Thea no triangles
involved if measuring this angle around
that's the dark do you see this is a
really big deal right because and this
is why they're called circular functions
right they run the train comes here at
least no triangles that I need to draw
right cos theta sine theta simply come
from where am I on the circumference
according to what angle you've given me
okay
does that make sense now as you'll see
in the next five minutes this definition
is so so much better than our old
definition it's far more powerful it's
far broader and it yields a lot of
insights okay
so just before I leave this okay um
what's ten
it's just the ratio between the wine
excuse
okay